[Music]
hello i'm sanyan and this is my fellow
presenter inna
hi we are both media artists and
research assistant of kaist
we would like to first of all thank to
jesus conference korea for having us
and everyone who are watching this video
today we are very excited to talk about
our project
p-pipe for pt plus which addresses
the issues of including order alerts to
coding education
so the major goal of people for 50 plus
was to
contribute in enhancing the physical
emotional and lingual accessibility
of middle-aged and older people to
learning coding with people ideas
before continuing our before continuing
into our presentation
we'd like to briefly introduce
processing foundation fellowship program
which supported the pipeli 450 plus
project
if you are also wish to engage in the
community
by enhancing accessibility to creative
coding with processing
p5.js or mljs you might also wanna
you might also wanna consider applying
for next year's fellowship
so check out the link if you are
interested
we want to start our presentation by
answering this question that many people
would ask us
why creative coding education for 50
plus
basically it started from our very
personal wish to
better communicate with our parents and
grandparents
about what we love to do
and yet if you look deeper in the korean
society
you can notice some intertwined problems
that
our parents and grandparents generations
are facing
while digital interfaces and
interactions consist
of substantial part of daily life in
korea
more than half of the half of the older
population feel
as though they cannot access what has
become the dominant way of communicating
with their surroundings even more
difficulties are found
among those who went through their
public and former education before the
1970s
which was only the dawn of the computer
education in korea
to cope with these circumstances the
government has recently offered
digital education for instance on
learning computer software programs and
smartphones
however fewer than one percent of the
welfare
programs teach coding
unlike the current trend of welfare
policy
we hypothesized that increasing the
opportunity for learning coding would be
particularly helpful
for older adults in raising their
confidence
towards these interfaces and
interactions
in a way it is about learning a language
for
directly communicating with a
computational entity
understanding how the computer thinks
and how
it responds in that sense
we consider p5.js to be a perfect
starter
language especially for those unfamiliar
with machines
because the inputs outputs processes and
entire logical flows can be intuitively
delivered with a variety of interactions
in fact 500 people from around the world
also from older age group have
expressed their high interest in
learning coding for the following
reasons
one to overcome their fear towards the
digital environment
two to enhance their cognitive abilities
three to re-educate themselves for
planning for their later life
to better document the older people's
actual needs in coding education
we interviewed 13 people with average
a average age 62. these interviewers
have commonly appealed their interest in
learning
new technology and are willing to go
outdoors for learning
and they expressed their preference in
learning together with people
who share similar challenges
one thing to note about older adults
demographics
in korea is that they demonstrate high
confidence in using smartphones as well
based on this based on based on this
this finding without holding a p5.js
workshop specifically dedicated to
older adults itself can contribute in
increasing
the learning opportunity for older
population
in fact coding education has actively
been adopted in both public and former
and private and informal institutions
over the last decades in korea
and learning resources are getting
bountiful both online and
offline however those materials are
those materials and circumstance
curriculums are
not very suitable for 50 plus people
i think in i can talk more about this
right ina uh yes thank you sonya
so we started designing this workshop in
consideration of the technical access of
older adults
to coding devices like in our formative
interview the older adults demonstrated
their confidence and familiarity to
smartphones so we thought wish the
device a way through which we can access
with smartphones
the p5.js learning resources and also to
utilize web editor without a separate
or refresh window and what's even better
is that we can
utilize this smartphone to learn
the p5.js anytime and anywhere we want
and in this talk actually we've also
planned to introduce our p5 450 plus
workshop
our experiences there by um but due to
the reverse think of it 19 unfortunately
it's been delayed to late november
and yet the overview of the workshop you
can see from the current slide
so if you're also interested in learning
more about this workshop itself
and the actual voice of older adults on
their experiences of learning p5.js with
smartphones
please stay tuned till then but before
everything in preparing for p5.js
workshop in korea especially for those
those workshops that are targeting older
adults the korean translation of
materials
is a must so it is important to note
that the
english it comes as a double blind for
non-english speaking
people when learning coding since code
is written in english
and most of the learning materials in
online forums circulate in english
so as a part of minimizing this lingual
barrier we translated the official
website of p5.js in korean
so that not only our worship
participants but also the entire korean
speaking population can better access
the bountiful resources on this website
just one thing to note the sketch
backgrounds was created by zhang yan in
celebration of launching korean version
of the website
singing can you um briefly talk about
your work too
thank you so the artwork is my
reinterpretation
of human javemb with pipajiis
human genome is the native script of the
korean characters and language
invented and promulgated by king sejung
in 1446 i found much similarity between
king sejung's intention of creating
hunger characters
with the spirit of pipa js
especially in terms of enhancing
everyone's accessibility
to lingual experiences
yeah so likewise in our project outcomes
we try to include not only korean but
also the average english
and digital utilization level of older
adults to readjust the learning
materials so in that sense we also
thought
that unlike the usual way of learning
coding p5.js can be particularly helpful
in enhancing older adults understanding
of coding in multi-sensory manners
we thought it was crucial to offer a
wide variety of options for exploring
example sketches with readily accessible
codes through p5.js web editor
so this way they can try out their the
interaction and tweak with codes
and see how the entire process of
programming works like from their inputs
to outputs and if you're also looking
for p5.js sketches you might also
um you might you might want to explore
this showcase.p5.js.org
is the p5.js 2020 showcase website
produced and created by coney leo
it introduces 60 and more p5.js projects
that are categorized on their specific
themes or interactions such as data
visualization
game and sound typography etc
so all these aforementioned ideas to our
project are capstoned
in this prototype you can access on
p5450.plus
like we've constantly emphasized we
discovered a strong
need for learning for a learning
interface that's special
that's uh specially designed for 50-plus
people
our interviews demonstrated higher
confidence in using a smartphone than
desktop pcs or laptops
so we wanted to create a mobile-based
web application
so that they can access p5.js materials
and the
web editor simply through a single url
on their smartphones
again anytime and anywhere that we want
and without the barrier
of the barrier or burden of carrying
around a laptop or a tablet
or without downloading an application on
their phone
in case of p5.js web editor we embedded
that in our application so that the
learners can practice coding
customize example codes save and manage
their codes without a separate or
refresh window so this prototype is
uh it's basically like a simplified
version of p5.js.org which is the
official website of p5.js
we kept the structure and design
elements of p5.js org
but used less text and bigger phones
made more visual elements and
interactions come to the front
and place more focus on the basic
concepts of computer programming
with hopefully an easier user flow the
official website of pt5.js
is reintroduced as advanced information
through hyperlinks
so when we propose the p5450 plus web
application
as a stepping stone towards the festival
website or any other resources that are
bountiful but text oriented this is to
boost the
age group's confidence and self-learning
through smartphones
we hope that users feel at ease and have
fun with exploring the web application
and then eventually move on to p5.js org
or other resources through hyperlinks
for more
in-depth knowledge without being
overwhelmed by the depths of it at first
sight
so in our p5 450 plus workshop we'll be
fully utilizing this web application in
line with
analog or tangible media and contents in
our case we're using pen markers and
color papers so that the participants
can actually draw sketches that they
want to code later
or write down codes and we're printing
out the
code sketches in a4 science and we're
framing the sketches so that the
participants can have a mini exhibition
and take away their materialized results
of coding
as for bringing brainstorming on their
code sketches we're asking them to
recall their personal memory and stories
as a means to reinforce their cognition
such tasks include
visualizing of the visualization of
their own written
the daily written or their self portrait
of their
past present or future selves drawings
of their beloved living creatures
objects
or a roadmap to their favorite places
and their neighborhood landscaping etc
in designing
the curriculum we have not only referred
to cognition reinforcement education
programs for the older adults but also
the learning methodology and materials
demonstrated
at other p5.js workshops or classes
so for your reference we'd like to
introduce that you can now access
information to p5.js workshops and
classes and relevant teaching materials
through this page that's newly launching
the september
the url is p5js.org teach
and the page was designed to document
and share prefetch's
teaching experiences around the world
it's constantly receiving submissions on
the teaching cases so if you've got any
you might want to consider sharing yours
through this webpage as well
as for our show we have referred to
these two workshops in particular
which you can also check out on the
teach page so on the left you can see
lauren mccarthy's workshop who is the
very creator of
p5.js and also the advisor to our
project so lauren has led
the smarter home workshop in south korea
last year
where a fair fair amount of participants
were middle-aged and older
and they engaged in the two-month-long
collaborative p5 projects for an
exhibition
her experience let us ponder more on the
re-engagement and sustainability issue
of learning coding
so to quote her teaching coding
sometimes is not about losing people
it's about how to keep them engaged
instead of scaring them away
now on the right side you can see
chinchinnier and evenly masters
chinchin was the mentor to our project
and together with evelyn she led a
series a workshop called
digital weaving physical computing
in this workshop participants
transformed their codes into tangible
materials such as fabric
their workshop to how we can their
workshop has
let us think more about how we can
leverage tangible materials
and interactions and then to promote a
more intuitive and affectionate way of
learning coding
so combining our research and the
insight from our
mentor and advisor as well as other p5
educators
we could devise some principles to
design mp5 for 50 plus workshops
so uh we believe a p5.js workshop can
start from asking
the reason why participants would want
to learn coding
and how the experience can be beneficial
for them
this is not only to inform them of
social cultural functions and effects of
computer programming in the
contemporary society but also to keep
them motivated throughout the workshop
now keeping the learning materials and
environment physically and emotionally
accessible is never too much to
emphasize
in our case we've considered their
physical accessibility to computing
devices
the lingua accessibility and the
universal design of learning interfaces
and these three in a row we can talk
about it all together at once
so we think it's important to utilize um
multi-sensory elements of p5.js and
sensorializing the participants personal
narratives
and then materialize the results from
digital to analog media so that they can
take away their learning experience with
a souvenir
we're also considering the souvenir as
an at-home device for recalling their
memories of learning coding so that they
won't forget to re-access p5450.plus
when they wish to continue learning
once again to emphasize um this is one
common methodology actively employed in
the fields of gerontology
or the studies of the um um older adults
or studies of rehabilitation in terms of
improving the feedback
uh i'm in terms of improving the 50-plus
learners understanding of concentration
on
and affection towards what they are
learning
providing a time and space for social
interactions with other people in the
midst of workshop would be helpful
by social interactions we mean those
moments where you can communicate with
those
people who share similar backgrounds
interests
and challenges or better yet with their
own family members
note that in korea in case of korea the
alienation and generational gap issues
are biggest challenges to older adults
last but not least important to note
that for educators themselves to enjoy
their moments of teaching
so let us enjoy teaching and learning
from our participants
this is all for our presentation thank
you very much for your attention and if
you have any questions please do not
hesitate to leave comments this video
or send us an email thank you very much